you know the wall street journal asked
this question this week in an article is
is joe biden basically the new george
costanza from seinfeld where every
single instinct this man has is wrong
maybe if he did the opposite of his
instincts the country would be in a
different spot folks the man is a
disaster i've resorted to calling joe
biden the king of pain he must be doing
this intentionally we are in an
inflation crisis right now keep in mind
as i said in the monologue none of this
is new we had an inflation crisis in
this country before ronald reagan
inherited one you can look at the
numbers go ch check a history book if
you're a liberal inflation was through
the roof so what did ronald reagan do
ronald reagan cut taxes to juice the
supply side of the economy to create
more supply of products and what
happened gdp exploded here's another you
can see it you could go look up the
numbers what happened in the reagan
years gdp six and seven percent gdp
growth during the reagan years he
inherited inflationary crisis worse than
what joe biden has now and you know what
they didn't do they there it is right
there you can see it they did not spend
a boatload of money more than they
needed to spend they cut taxes and put
them back in the producers hand so they
could produce goods to suck up all this
excess money in the economy the federal
reserve raised interest rates and
eventually we got back to growth now
there were debts and deficits in the
reagan years no doubt but we have never
seen debt and deficits like this in u.s
history nothing even comparable since
world war ii so what's joe biden's
instincts well just like george costanza
every instinct is wrong he wants to
print more money and raise more taxes to
take more money out of your wallet as
he's printing more money to chase fewer
goods because nobody's gonna have any
money to invest in their businesses to
produce stuff
the george costanza presidency they
nailed it in the wall street journal hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else